okay so the topic of this video right
here will be our sense of hearing so
let's go ahead and get started
well with our sense of hearing let's
first of all learn some of the anatomy
of the ear and it begins with our pinna
the fleshy outer part of the ear and it
acts as a funnel so sound from our
environment is funneled into our inner
ear canal because of this fleshy flap of
tissue called the pin and of course
people over the years have ceremony only
directed and adorned our pin in a
variety of ways with piercings and and
various objects but you know you ask
yourself you know when we can't hear
somebody talk you know we will often cup
our hands behind our ears well this
actually helps to funnel even more sound
into our ear canal
so we can hopefully hear what the person
might be saying so here we have a
diagram and we've labeled now the pinna
well let's move inward into the ear
canal we come to the eardrum and what
the eardrum does is it transfers sound
from the air from the environment from
into the middle of our ear well we're
going to go inward further into this
diagram so just inward more to the right
of the eardrum are these three very
small bones what are collectively known
as the ossicles we have the malleus we
have the incus and we have the stabies
and these are very small bones the stay
piece is no bigger than the size of a
grain of rice so three of some of these
smaller bones in the body and these are
known as the ossicles and what they help
to do is they help to amplify sound in
the process of us hearing we'll talk
more about this in a moment so the next
part of our anatomy I want to focus on
is this curly almost sea shell shaped
bone inside of the inner ear called the
cochlea and like the notes say inside of
the cochlea there are these
mechanoreceptors that we call hair cells
now mechanoreceptors detect pressure and
hair cells they detect pressure and and
the pressure that they detect is
actually going to be interpreted as
sound by our brain and so it's these
hair cells that are going to ultimately
produce the impulses the action
potentials that will lead into our brain
for us to hear sound so let's go into
this in a little more detail okay so in
sound transmission let's say you're
listening to some music so the first
thing that happens is sound waves which
are simply vibrations in the ear are
going to be funneled into your ear canal
by your pinna so we have sound waves
have now entered our ear canal and
that's gonna cause our eardrum to begin
to vibrate now in my animation I've I've
over exaggerated of course the vibrating
of the eardrum just so we can see it
better in my animation but the sound
waves that enter our ear canal will
cause our eardrum to vibrate this causes
those three bones collectively called
the ossicles to vibrate the malleus the
incus and the stapes so the vibrations
of the eardrum are carried on to the
ossicles the malleus the incus and the
stapes and that vibration is then passed
along to the cochlea which is that
Curley shaped bone inside more
internally located inside of our ear and
if you recall we said earlier what's
inside of the cochlea is what's really
special in this case because inside of
the cochlea the cochlea is not a you
know empty and hallow there is a fluid
inside of the cochlea and here we have a
picture of some of those hairs that are
sticking up from hair cells these are
actually actually cilia which we learned
way back earlier in the school year
certain cells have little parts too
that stick out of them called cilia and
so here we have some a grouping of hair
cells and you can see the cilia sticking
out of them and when the cochlea begins
to vibrate that causes the flu
would inside of the cochlea to kind of
rush over and slosh around a little bit
and that causes the cilia to bend and
it's that bending of the cilia of these
hair cells that's going to trigger an
action potential so an impulse is then
triggered once these hairs are these
cilia on the hair cells begin to vibrate
and so now that the cochlea their I
should say now that the hair cells
located inside of the cochlea have begun
to bend they've created action
potentials and air impulses and you can
see there's another part of the diagram
that I've added a label to and that's
called the auditory nerve this is the
nerve where the impulse or the action
potential will travel from the cochlea
up the auditory nerve and directly into
the brain and of course it's your brains
job to then interpret this signal as
sounds that we hear throughout our day
and there you go there's a real quick
overview of you know the general pathway
and how we hear so if you're in my class
you know try to answer these questions
I'd have I'm happy to check their
answers before school or after school